- We are going to prank
my boyfriend this morning
with 1,000 roses.
They're going to be delivered,
we're gonna foot him the
bill at the end, too.
(rock music)
- Davis and I have been
together for two years,
and we've never pranked each other before,
but he loves surprising me.
So this is my opportunity to surprise him
with the ultimate prank.
I'm taking Davis out to brunch,
and when we get back,
there will be 1,000 roses delivered
by actors that we've hired
to deliver the flowers to my apartment.
So while Davis and I are at brunch,
the crew is setting up cameras
all over my apartment,
and then they're gonna
hide in my sister's room
while the prank is happening.
I have no idea how he's going to react,
but please don't hate me!
Hey, what's up?
- [Sister] Hey how are you?
- [Davis] What's up?
- [Sister] How's it going?
- [Lauren] Good.
- We have 1,000 roses here
and we're about to do an epic rose prank.
(knocking on door)
- Who's that?
When I hear the knock on the door,
I'm terrified because
this is really happening.
Hi!
What's up?
- I have a rose delivery for Lauren.
- When Davis sees them,
he has no idea what's going on.
(laughs) That's me.
Cool, oh my God!
Those are gorgeous. (laughs)
Wow!
He mentioned that he had a few surprises
planned for Valentine's Day,
so I'm gonna play into that.
Did you?
- I did not!
- Yes you did!
- I do like surprises, but...
- Is this Valentine's Day?
- No, it's the seventh!
- They keep bringing in
more and more flowers.
I don't even think they'll
fit in my apartment.
- You must be Davis, right?
Can I just get your signature?
- For what?
- Just the invoice?
(laughter)
- It's 3,625.44.
- When we told him how
much it was going to be,
I could just see the stress piling on.
- I don't have 3,000
dollars to pay you for...
- It's 3,625.44.
I don't wanna step on,
if you guys have been
dating for two years, maybe,
isn't she worth it?
- Oh absolutely!
She's worth far more than that!
- You send them as a surprise--
- There's an entire day of
surprises planned for the 14th.
This is not inclusive.
- Can you say, just say for the record,
"I'm not gonna pay for them?"
Can you just turn around to
that camera that's right there?
And say, "I'm not gonna
pay for these roses?"
Cause you just got pranked!
(laughter)
- Practical solution.
- You don't have to spend
3,000 dollars. (laughs)
He was such a good sport about it.
- I've never seen anyone get that many
flowers of any kind
delivered for anything.
This might actually be the
first time I've been pranked.
- If we're gonna start a pranking thing
in our relationship now,
I don't know where we can go from here.
This is the top, we hit the top of pranks.
(cheerful music)